wednesday pft pm from the barn continues
with the man who will always be known at
least by me is the guy who found patrick
mahomes he is chief's general manager
brett veach brett welcome back to the
program how are you pal mike thanks uh
for having me on excited to you know
share some time with you here and i'm
doing good and now the draft's over here
we can all take a deep breath and have a
side release well i have a quiz for you
a pop quiz because we did not discuss
this in advance i want to know
if you know
the grade that mel keiper gave your 2017
draft do you know what that grade is i
do not no
i don't do you want to make a guess um
[Music]
i'll
keep it right down the middle and say b
c plus
okay
yeah drafted bro patrick my homes to
town and kareem hunt and my point here
isn't the bag on mel but this is a
continuation of something i was talking
to howie rosen about yesterday the idea
that this whole process of even trying
to grade drafts is impossible because we
don't know and we won't know how these
guys work out until it's time to go line
up on a field against other
nfl caliber talent grown ass men
and how those guys react in that setting
will let us know whether or not it's a
good pick
well yeah i mean you're absolutely right
i mean these guys have to come in here
and um you know all the stuff that we
watched and evaluated on tape we certain
teams will have different beliefs in in
in regards to how they see players but
we're certainly excited about the the
group we brought in and
i do want to you know give you a little
tip of the cap there right toward i
would say that the 24th hour going into
this draft you know typically
right before the draft you have an
indication of maybe not exactly who
you're going to get but but two or three
guys and you know when i had a chance to
talk to coach reed um
the guy that we ended up really kind of
figuring out that this would make sense
for us was clyde edward solaire and then
i think two hours later uh you posted
your one and only mock and that's who
you had you had us taken so uh i sent
that to coach so of all the the draft
experts you guys gotta kind of got that
one right huh well first of all the
blind squirrel feasts on acorn from time
to time second of all i don't do the
mock draft i have somebody who used to
be an nfl personnel who puts it together
for me and this year especially i wasn't
in a position to second guess because
who the hell knew how it was going to
play out this year because there wasn't
that group think that we usually get
from the pro day workouts when people
get together and compare notes chris
sims also had clyde edward solaire at
number 32. so we both pegged it even
though i really didn't peg it but
chris was all over clyde edward solaire
as the best running back in the class
you obviously agreed when you hear that
kind of stuff before the draft when you
know the momentum is pushing toward
deandre swift and he was the betting
favorite and he was the guy everyone was
saying would be the first running back
taken when you see someone like sims
saying clyde edwards hilaire is the best
when you see him show up being given to
you at pick number 32 and mark drafts do
you what do you do do you cringe do you
worry do you think you may have to trade
up to get him how does that how does
that affect you well i mean that's
that's a good question you know there's
so many of these guys you know that that
do this and and certainly um we felt the
same as as uh um
as chris but you know there's so many
guys that do this so you know if you go
down that alley i mean where you're
gonna where does it stop and start and
where does it end so uh i think we all
take notes of that kind of stuff and we
do look at it uh but at the end of the
day you know we're gonna stick to our
beliefs and and what we value on our
board and what we think is best for the
chiefs but
i mean sure you're going to see a lot of
these things but like i said there's
there's so many of them out there that
um sometimes it's it works in your favor
and sometimes it doesn't as you prepared
for and executed this draft brett did
you
feel less pressure because you guys are
the champs you've got patrick mahomes no
matter what even if none of the picks
work out you've still got my homes or
did you feel more pressure because once
he gets that second contract the
lifeblood of your team is going to be
the draft picks who are under rookie
weight scale contracts low cost fit
under the salary cap we got to hit on
these guys we got to get contributors
out of these guys or it's not going to
work around a highly paid quarterback
yeah i certainly think that you know you
always feel pressure and um i don't
think that because we won a super bowl
we felt less so i would say that every
year every draft there's a lot of
pressure to
do the homework and make the best
evaluations you can i would say if
anything there was a little bit more
pressure like you said you know there
are some some guys that um we have to
figure out their contracts and and you
know the best way to uh keep this thing
rolling is to you know
add in young town on on rookie contracts
so i would say if anything that there
was more pressure um really that and i
think that the stress and probably the
unknown of uh after the draft the free
agency period was something that i think
we all got to a mindset of going into
the draft that um you know once we got
the communication i thought the league
did a pretty good job of of getting us
up to speed and everything ran smoothly
we were really worried about um you know
the undrafted free agent period um as
you know that gets a little crazy but
i think entering the draft
you know we certainly understood you
know the magnitude of
um obtaining uh talent that is going to
sustain this thing as we work through
some of these uh star players on our
roster with bigger contracts how much
different was the undrafted free agent
period that process of of engaging in
the land rush for the guys who weren't
picked how different was it this year
than it is in a normal year well it's
always it's always crazy and you know i
think in normal years when you're in a
facility you have the um ability to pass
off the phone and and talk to your
medical people and and recruit players
because once you get to the end of the
draft all 32 teams are on the clock for
for a player not like you know you have
time to figure out what you want to do
and sometimes these players um
you know they're trying to figure out
what's the best fit for them where they
want to go
um working with their agents and by the
time they get back to you
um with a no the next three or four guys
are off the board um but
you know i think in a weird way mike uh
and we joked about this before the draft
not having a sixth and seventh round
pick now we ended up trading back into
the seventh but at the time our last
pick was in the fifth round so that gave
us some lead in time so we were really
able to kind of look at the landscape
and project where guys would be
um and once we got off the clock we knew
exactly where we're where we wanted to
go that kind of logic led into us
trading back in because looking at the
corners that were left in the sixth and
seventh round we figured um the player
we selected wouldn't be there so um
you know
give credit to my staff i think that you
know we
devoted
a lot of time into the um after the
draft for agency process and i think
that we're able to come away with some
good players
give me something that you were worried
about brett something that was causing
you to lose sleep about how this draft
was going to unfold that ended up being
no big deal at all
yeah it was the last second trade type
scenario i think that was the one thing
i think you know we we had our board and
you know we were fortunate that you know
we spent 16 or 17 days as a staff before
the combine to really lay down the
foundation of our board so 80
of our board was done before the combine
now we had some um some back-end work to
do and we had to devote some additional
resources to getting more information
and doing a lot of zoom chats and doing
stuff with the medical um but when we
finally got to the draft after the lead
gave us a good two-week window to kind
of prep and do some demo runs on making
calls and talking to teams we felt
really confident i think the one thing
that i was concerned about was okay
we're on the clock we have a player we
like and then maybe with like 45 seconds
a team would call with an interesting
trade um
proposal and then just making sure that
everybody's on the same page in zoom
chats um as opposed to being there in
real time and certainly making sure we
didn't lose a connection but the league
was also very cooperative in the sense
that you know they let us know that if
you did have a technical issue right
toward the end that they would be
lenient and just be open and communicate
with them so that was probably the one
scenario but it never really came into
play well and as it always seems to go
in the real world it's the thing you
worry about that isn't an issue and it's
the thing you didn't worry about that
becomes an issue is there something that
wasn't on your radar screen that during
the draft you realized holy crap i
should have been ready for this
um you know i think every year it's
probably um
being out of a selection
when there are a few more guys available
there than you thought uh you know we
all try to
and for the most part the first round
goes relatively
um on point but once you get into rounds
two or three uh you're kind of in your
mind eyeing guys that you're like this
guy i think will be there we're excited
he'd help us and then all of a sudden
you know you get to that pick and
there's another two guys that you
probably projected to go a little higher
now they're there um and so balancing
out um you know can you trade back um
you know in which direction do you go
and that's where all that advanced
dialogue comes into play and that's
where you know once you set the board
you stick true to it so there was a few
scenarios where you know we kind of
targeted guys in in specific rounds uh
guys tended to fall a little bit lower
and then were available to us um and
those are the scenarios that happen
every year though
we talked about clyde edward saleh the
running back from lsu
what would you say to placate the
concerns of any fans out there who are
of that mindset that an nfl team should
never use a first round pick on a
running back that they can be found
anywhere you shouldn't burn up that high
of a pick on a guy that you can get in
rounds two three four five all the way
through to undrafted free agency like an
aryan foster what do you say to the
folks who would insist no way know how
should you use a first round pick on a
running back well i think every draft is
different and every evaluation is is is
different in regards to how you process
this information i think that most teams
in general um you know taking the
quarterback out of the equation because
the quarterback's the ultimate anomaly
but most teams operate with the mindset
of you're going to build you know
through the middle so you're going to
build o-line d-line and then work on the
corners um and we're no different in
that we operate with that mindset too so
we're always going to look to solidify
our offensive line and our defensive
line in fact i think if you looked at
what we've done um since i got here we
devoted a ton of resources up front on
the defense line and um you know what we
did in the draft with our offensive line
acquisitions um certainly speaks to that
but
i think that
when you uh enter the first round of
this draft and you're being true with
your evaluations there's always going to
be an outlier to every scenario you're
in so when you're there in the first
round and you have a mindset of how you
want to build the team
and then you're also faced with the
question of but there's this what we
believe to be a franchise running back
uh a true playmaker and another addition
to pat mahomes i think that comes into
play so it's really our evaluation of
clyde edward solar and what we think of
him and his ability um and is he you
know is he a guy that you can just find
in the fourth or fifth round or is he
someone special and unique and we
certainly viewed him as someone special
and unique
damien williams was your leading rusher
last year he had the 90-yard touchdown
run in the win over minnesota he had the
back-breaking touchdown in the super
bowl victory have you or coach reed
spoken to him about what this draft pick
of clyde edward solaire means to damien
williams yeah so you know i got a chance
to speak with his agent and um you know
reached out to him via text and i know
coach reached out to him uh via text
right before the pick and then i think
he followed up with him um recently in
the last few days but i mean look these
guys are all all super competitive and i
think
like any player in this league when a
team drafts someone at your position i
don't think they're doing backflips and
high fives and i i think that the
competitiveness certainly comes out but
i think once these guys come into the
building
and once you get this thing rolling i
think
you know everyone kind of gels as a
cohesive unit um but
our situation is is good for for
certainly clyde where chilera and damien
because these guys will be really good
complementary players to one another and
that's really the question too is it
clyde edward hiller becoming the
workhorse or do you see it more of a
shared load between edward hillaire and
williams
no i i certainly think it's going to be
um a a shared load i mean listen damian
is has been in this offense now for for
a long time and certainly showed what he
can do in that playoff run uh the guy's
really good pass protector can catch the
football i mean both these guys you know
can run and catch um and you know
certainly damien will come in as a
starting running back and clyde will
have to come in here and compete uh for
playing time which we think he'll do but
i think it'll be a good one-two punch
one of the realities of the pandemic
that i hadn't thought about really until
just before we got this started brett a
ring ceremony for the kansas city chiefs
what are the plans in light of the fact
that things are still kind of upside
down with the coronavirus that's a good
question and i i don't have the answer
for that you know i'm certainly i'm sure
clark hunt and mark donovan are are on
top of that and
i'd like to think that they didn't want
to really interrupt coach and i during
this process here but you know we were
just locked in uh with the with the free
agency process before the draft and then
locked in really with all the um uh
technology uh prior to the draft here so
uh i don't know about that but i'm sure
that once we get back to a full
operating capacity that'll be something
we all look forward to one of the issues
that's come up brett in the
uh in the wake of the pandemic and the
likelihood that the off-season programs
will be gone or at least limited very
limited at most um
signing your draft picks we've seen
since 2011 a lot of teams jump on it
early they get their picks signed do you
have a strategy that's been revised to
fit the current reality as to whether or
not you're going to move forward you're
going to wait do you have a timetable
for when you're going to sign these guys
yeah i think that i mean we'll probably
just proceed as as you know we have in
the past um
you know i i think we have a little bit
of a window here um you know it doesn't
look like we'll be in the office anytime
soon so i you know
i'm sure that there in the past were
weeks where we probably came out very
soon and got some of these guys done
right away i'm sure they're probably a
little bit of hold over in regards to
both parties just assessing all the
information uh you know made available
to at the time so
you know i don't think this will hold
things up but i do think that there'll
be some extra time given um to make sure
that we have all the information in
regards to how everything's going to
proceed as we move on here linebacker
willie gay jr was your second round pick
tell us what attracted you to him
well i mean that's a really interesting
player obviously a supremely gifted
athlete um when we had the the
pre-combine meetings um with our
scouting staff i mean he kind of jumped
off tape now he had the academic issue
where he was suspended and the tape was
a little choppy but i think if you look
at what he was able to do in those four
or five games and then go back to last
year um the guy certainly has um you
know a crazy athletic skill set um has
range has versatility i think he can
cover um extremely well and then also
because he's a bigger type prospect
that's a little longer he can also play
sam or will for us so we're really
excited about that and then he goes to
the combine he put on performance that
um you know
was as good as any linebacker's
performance in the last 5-10 years here
so we certainly think that there'll be a
little bit of a learning curve with
willie just because you know he hasn't
taken a lot a large volume of reps in
college but the limited amount of reps
he did have at that level were super
impressive and we certainly know that
his ceiling is extremely high given his
uh athletic athletic testing numbers one
of the benefits for the chiefs in 2020
bringing back so many of the starters
from the team that won super bowl 54.
is there a downside though to having
that much continuity and that there's a
greater chance of complacency when you
don't maybe have
a new guy who joins the team a veteran
who's hungry for a ring that maybe keeps
guys from getting satisfied in what
happened last year how do you guard
against that complacency when you have
so many of those starters coming back
who had just climbed at the top of the
mountain and are back at the bottom
trying to climb the same mountain again
yeah you trust the leadership you have
in your locker room and you're right to
the point that when when we lost to new
england uh in the afc championship game
a couple years ago um you know that that
fire and that drive kind of fueled our
entire offseason um you know not just
the players but what we did as an
organization in regards to being
aggressive and making moves uh but we
you know we came so close and we were
driven by that fire uh like you said now
that you've gotten there and you won the
super bowl um you know we have to do a
great job of maintaining that same level
of focus and aggressiveness that put us
in the position um that we're in so i
think these are the times and and you
know when you have success you really um
fall back uh on the leadership you have
in that locker room and i think having
pat mahomes on the offensive side and ty
and matthew on the defensive side is
where what we're really going to bank on
the patrick mahomes contract comes up
from time to time do you have a
timetable for when there will be an
effort to get him under contract well
into the future
well i mean certainly
being the best player in the nfl is is
goes to the the top of the list for us
um i don't know if we can put a time
table um with both him and a player like
chris jones you're talking about really
two obviously um two players that are at
the top of their positions and these are
going to be um you know
the contracts are going to certainly be
on the larger scale of things and um
they'll take some time but you know
chris is a little bit different than pat
because you know he has a deadline of
there's a july 15th deadline to get
something done but i think with both
players now here um now the draft's over
and we have um some time now to kind of
shift gears and look toward what we hope
is a full offseason and certainly we
don't know and no one does but um we'll
be able to
kind of turn our our resources and our
focus into working um with these two um
these two camps to get to get both
players done and it is such a deadline
driven business brett that with chris
jones it's easy it's july 15. that's the
deadline for a multi-year deal that's
when everybody knows the clock is going
to hit midnight for patrick mahomes
though you have a broader period of time
that you can play with are you getting
any
agitation any frustration any sense from
mahomes side that they want to do it now
no no not at all but you know i'm
certainly
we know that we would like to get
something done um sooner than later and
i certainly know that they feel the same
way
you know you're when you kind of go
through the last few few months here i
think we've all realized it's been a
crazy time for the whole country um so
with a crazy free agency period combined
with um a new never been done before
virtual draft um certainly in our early
dialogue dialogue with um you know pat
and his uh representatives we kind of
knew that once things settled down um
we'd be able to to open up dialogue and
and proceed but i mean look we all want
to get it done it'll take time like all
these big deals do but um
i guess the best thing to say mike is
you know
he'll be a kansas city chief for the
duration of his career and we feel
confident about that you know one of the
challenges you have is a practical
matter brett and and like you said so
much has changed so much is happening
you got to plan for how the world is
going to unfold
and
if we do have a season with no fans in
the stands or limited fans in the stands
that's going to affect the bottom line
that's going to affect the salary cap
for 2021
how much of that planning goes into play
when you get to the point whether it's
negotiating chris jones patrick holmes
or anybody the possibility that the cap
may actually go down we've never seen it
go down and you're gonna have less
dollars available for everyone and you
want to be careful how much gets tied up
into your your highest paid players
well i mean yeah that's certainly an
excellent point and i think as you
mentioned
any player that that you're looking to
do and whether it be the chiefs or any
team we're all dealing with the same
information there's a great um
great part of this is is the unknown so
i think that you know patience um will
certainly uh have to come into play here
in regards to just making sure that um
you know we monitor uh certainly what's
going on throughout the country getting
great dialogue from the league um as we
proceed but um it's it's we are in a
little bit of a a tricky window here
where we're kind of just projecting uh
in a lot of ways of you know how many
games will we play when we'll start will
this be a full season will will there be
fans and really none of those questions
we have any definitive answers to right
now so there is a a little bit of a
holding pattern here um and we'll
certainly use utilize that holding
pattern to acquire all the information
we can to make good decisions moving
forward but you're right to the point of
how all these things could could you
know come into play uh two three years
down the line
one thing i need to ask you about before
i let you go the bashad breeland arrest
i hadn't seen a team statement on that
is there any comment whatsoever on the
news out of i believe south carolina or
north carolina of the incident with
rashad breeland oh yeah so we were made
aware of the situation uh yesterday and
um you know we're certainly um uh
um
going to defer to the league and and you
know the local authorities down there
and um we'll do what we always do we'll
kind of look at all the information and
have great communication and dialogue
dialogue with the league and and kind of
let the situation work itself out it's
got to be frustrating too in a normal
situation you'd be able to bring him in
sit him down talk to him see how he's
doing that's one of the questions that
never gets asked in a situation like
this how are you doing you've just been
arrested it's a contentious situation is
there anything we can do to help you you
can't have that in-person conversation
it's got to be harder to take the
temperature of where a guy is
well certainly and
you know just in general though i think
all these guys are anxious uh to get to
get back into uh uh their facilities you
know it's funny mike you know over the
years a lot of these guys uh after the
seasons don't really wanna come back and
you always have that is he going to show
up for otas as he's not i feel like this
year we have so many players calling and
just dying to get back so uh this may
end up being a good thing for the for
the the league moving forward in regard
so i think the guys are actually missing
otas where in the past you know some of
these guys rather be on extended
vacations it's got to be a real concern
though when guys show up for training
camp i'm sure one of the first jobs is
to get the doctors and the trainers
to know what kind of shape each guy's in
because i think every guy is going to
come in in some different level of shape
without that regimen without that
structure that we ordinarily would have
in the offices yeah
you're right and you know um especially
for you know when every team is
different in regards to how they they
run training camp we have certainly a
very demanding training camp and um you
know coaches is still a little bit
old-school in regards to the volume of
of things that we get done in that in
that time window there so um we've had a
lot of talk in early early dialogue in
regards to making sure that we have um
some you know advanced medical um set up
ready to go for our players but i
certainly think that they'll be
potentially a window of lead in time
before camp opens just to make sure that
these guys get all the proper proper
medical attention they need and make
sure that we can get a baseline of
physical conditioning for where these
guys are out to keep them all safe and
healthy well hopefully the people whose
job it is to come up with plans for a
football season will come up with a plan
to make it happen you'll get to open the
season at home on a thursday night
hopefully in early september and we'll
get to see if the chiefs can become the
first back-to-back champion since the
patriots in 2003 and 2004 brett
congratulations again on the super bowl
victory and all the best we look forward
to talking to you again soon mike i
appreciate it and i hope you and your
family are doing well and hope we can
catch up soon all right same to you
brett thanks thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports